what am i doing is is completely wrong
yeah hello and welcome to this video I
cannot change this and we can do it okay
so I want to make a quick video here and
I decide I decided to try something
which is probably a crazy idea with my
ideas - what idea
I'm just very late to the super blitz
and I was thinking I could try to catch
up 17 points probably too much but
Detroit have to observe a lot from a lot
hope a lot be lucky a lot yeah but it's
just the tournament that was available
so I'm going for it I asked you three if
he goes d43 isn't good yeah he 24 can
trade this though can I trade the dots
quit bishops and I'm going for that he
might play oh it looks like weakening
everything a lot you six now is
completely gone let's take it
Queen d5 though I have this move this is
very important okay take him and then I
should go out of this diagonal M
I have to trade stuff material up and it
doesn't really have anything for it
chick making would be better of course
with the time situation but I'm catching
up quite a bit I mean time situation
small I've got enough time to play this
game but I have to catch up in the
overall tournament so I better win
quickly
maybe I should rather play like money
for some turn I can oftentimes it's
better for me to not do that just play
what I usually do because I'm just
clicking finding ideas damn maybe I will
try night h4 so if it's something
something like that I can't
this h6 looks devastating this is the
thing and maybe next time okay so gain
250 points there are 50 places now that
it's it will be extremely difficult I
have to preserve a lot moving here
playing somewhat aggressively this
probably helped ie5 home now not so
happy now about that decision but it's
probably not that terrible Queen f-4s
funny that that could be a funny way to
win a piece a threatening made and
certain the bishop okay okay okay
what is happening here aged 393 that
doesn't work yeah just win some stuff
don't see a tactic win this okay
in the temple he might take it but I'm
ready 40 45 very quickly and then this
Bishop will be will be worse now gaining
more time I basically know just do it I
thought you had to offer the Queen trade
yeah Queen b6 Queen G three years is
over alright there's no no way to stop
this 9h for delay it one more
yeah look up each one 8h 5h4 for a
meeting met okay I am still far behind
but I truly get to maybe I will manage
to get to the first page I'm fairly
certain that is doable but of course I
cannot concede men you point them legal
[Music]
it's not my main line against the upon
speed can happen stop it
let's see there those nights a can be
pesky but I need just one check out on
the e-file and it's over but queen-to-be
five maybe that is the point
yeah see for threatening see for now
okay can I open this or what is he doing
here long casuals no 3193 now
I just grab that phone and then I need
more a little bit more firepower
I guess Queen a for coming
I'm taking the Queen it should also help
winning the Queen will c8 Quincy to
watch you'll probably know I thought you
would go look see one day I'm a queen
and taking too long up for this kind of
stuff
it also helps enormously if they
resigned sometimes that doesn't happen
okay yeah it takes long just takes a bit
too long yeah but okay
11 points just play every game and see
what happens
you can definitely kind of definitely
not afford to lose the game and wouldn't
really work sort of touch the fence
asking him about this piece where I see
going doesn't have many squares with it
[Music]
trying for 95 still try to use this v8
piece threatening before now I will see
hand like that b5 not a very happy move
okay I've won upon which is good but
notate anything decisive he might take
it to him I'm hoping that you don't I
didn't see that more coming it's
actually really really annoying if it
takes now Knight g4 I have to go h4
watches not what I wanted look good even
g5 is probably good might also be good
try it for loop p7 counter plane doesn't
react to the side yellow Knight f5 I
hope to get that in and then you will
click on e3 okay I mean this is of
course the complete win good time time
probably but I can try for making attack
yeah you know it's going to be really
tough for him to play against my two
books on the 7th enter knight on d5 now
taking a slow gauge have made so
Kazu f8 look at seven something very
annoying I can take skill garden growing
materials you just made them group g7
group B a check 25 points honest as
yours is leading maybe come on kiss
resigner this this is really not good
yes every right to continue don't get me
wrong with it to make this work you some
things you have to fall into place and
people letting the clock run down when
they are check mail snail
okay so 12 points behind mmm YUM 12
points yeah I can try 20 minutes whole
game so it's 4th place in the tournament
C 5 is a pretty good primo actually can
play it against anything
so bingo those flies are actually really
bad with me oh yeah let mean no time
with the this time control you can try
stuff of course but those in general it
really doesn't work against the bank on
this stuff
so I'm trying to attack his skin here
threatening to take table nc3 winning it
already has to do something against us
he doesn't really so I'm winning even
more stuff we're working
this book has very detailed squareness I
can actually take look Queen a foil this
is somehow and then I can go I can go to
f8 down
we should take this maybe would have
been better than maybe attend as in
quicker and they never resign not even
two looks everything down which is not
helping
so third place seven points behind and
the doctor has given some points you be
any millionaire should get this guy and
beaten it would help also the circus
Kings Indians can to be a bit easier for
for black to play in the QuickTime
controls it's my experience take such a
v6 will win this is also very good or
temple I get d5 and his Knight is dead
so the piece down effectively anything
that you can do here no trading is the
best just traded
the night is simply efficiently dead
Rick is running out of Nelson what gets
interesting don't like that it's no good
to them can take away your phone okay I
guess with the bishop pair that's nice
for no particular reason
I didn't see any reason for maybe
doesn't do that thought that would help
okay you know I'm just a bit better form
or the bone structure
ie4 don't know it's still better man you
too I can just take it - should have
done that now it still allows me to take
it
see for maybe can I cheek meat in hand
someone doesn't look like it but did it
look like before maybe trying to get to
g3 what are you doing Blaire
and it wasn't ideal but could still be
enough I've looped you for 56 okay
Butchie three anyway yes it's a whale
okay yeah hey I'm leading it worked I
still have to win the whole thing though
[Music]
stimulus you be ending Williams ready
play the drawing you know he's still on
I see that game yeah you don't see it
completely with should be a draw me I
should actually stop to the work we can
stir Harry did player like this one I
could be tricky
this should be seven that looks very
strange where are you going with this
I've got d5 green if he takes we might
lose just on the e-file
so difficult to develop take take
we should be six would be one it's
pretty pretty awful yeah yeah I can
click here to do this once
f ck Quincy eight and then just be six I
guess it will be tough one I wonder what
you're thinking I'm all you cannot go at
six in the situation that I absolutely
don't believe
okay so D takes is six let's make sure
that you will never cancel taking G five
with chick and threatening rookie one
not sure if it is a big threat though
but it looks okay
also 94 maybe 96 is also a good threat
okay the iron opening was that was
completely unplayable okay so leading by
five points
that's not bad considering that I was
just like 20 minutes later the event so
that is how default to that
close the door after the washing machine
warning that's number three and it's
actually bit risky to do that to do the
berserk here I could switch into this
horde mode which should not say it is a
bit weird make sure you never want to go
there but okay she takes it doesn't
doesn't help okay
I should be a bit quicker
should be a ch3 here is a somewhat
awkward pin yeah I can take take take
wings material Y is just a good position
check tink and I g8 wins wins the
exchange don't know it's probably enough
we see five we can actually take
important
nice good this free and chick which is
really unfortunate
yeah and this is not so easy I mean with
the time considered it is easy in
whatever tournament she'll probably have
to make this draw here
I mean time-release yeah and it was okay
with the tournament standing okay I
should win the game but was a little bit
awkward so I think I probably get one
more game in right with five points
ahead I have seen this yeah I was
leading such a tournament and then
always I was overtaken I was really
weird I just sighs okay no yeah that's
actually possible
[Music]
it's not very simple in this type of
room okay we got to cancel long it is it
certainly helps it this is not so nice
we should be high if is going to be no
doesn't do it not really happy with
taking you higher that's coming in which
is a completely I mean messy is a really
mild prescription for the stuff
completely from outer space through t1
you might just take seasick some now
doesn't do it high then you've got to
friggin e6e move I don't believe this
stuff oh my god it was just like
completely random came your take
yes unfortunately very easy and taking
is also you know I am such a [ __ ]
yeah as well
now looking what do you want them in the
opening is a little bit it's a bit
tricky this kids opening with no time
but of course I was totally winning of
course so I shouldn't complain some
complain too much a 96 this is funnier
with spawn so you just go to the Vienna
yeah anyway so a tournament pairings are
closed so I might maybe I get overtaken
the end was crap you had a draw and the
loss especially the loss was yeah not
really necessary maybe they would take
me so I'm winning with one point I don't
know is it exactly over now I don't know
okay so I made it yeah I made it and had
to berserk every single game and had one
point at the end yeah okay I hope you
enjoyed it it was a fun video and yeah I
will probably post some more over the
weekend yeah thanks for watching bye bye